I'm going to get a PET scan to make sure I'm clear now that I'm done with my surgery,
my reconstruction was January 8th. I want to ease my mind so I can move forward confidently.
I haven't been scanned with a CT since February 2023. It had an MRI pre-vestectomy on September 23,
since does that seem like a reasonable claim? Yeah, I do. So, yeah, I think that's a very reasonable
claim. Dr. Jens has to take 100 milligrams melatonin and 2 to 4,000 milligrams
liposol will see a hour or two prior to the scan to help protect from radiation.
Yeah, that's fine. I think that's fine too. I have both your MRI and CT,
holyopathics, which one of these do you take for a scan? So, not the MRI holyopathic,
the CT holyopathic. So, with PET scan, you're dealing not dealing with
catalytic, because that's what the MRI holyopath is, is catalytic, is the MRI contrast.
A PET scan is going to be radiation, so that's what you want to protect yourself against.
Is there anything else I need to know in order to avoid these false positives or mitigate
the side effects of a scan? Well, I don't think you have side effects of the PET scan. I don't think
you need to worry about that. As far as false positives on the PET scan, I don't think you need to be
concerned about that either. Where you see false positives is on an MRI or CT scan when you already
know you have a mass. And the false positive would be the false enlargement or pseudo enlargement of
a mass when it's just a inflammatory response, killing that cancer mass. So, that's not going to be
if you're concerned either. So, yeah, get that done and let's get the results back and see what that
looks like. That would be interesting. Any thoughts on those two lumps? So, if the PET scan
lights up at those two lumps, then you have to make a decision whether you're going to go ahead with
but they'll call. This is going to recommend is either surgery to remove those if they're
seen barely accessible or radiation. You already did conventional methods.
So, I don't know that I would be against moving forward if you felt confident and you felt
confident what the oncologist is going to recommend. So, I would get their advice
that I'll gladly chat with you about it. Yes, I'm doing surgery but the other treatment
but other treatment codes. From an alternative perspective,
I would change anything. The only thing I don't remember the last time we did a cheek swab or
something like that if we want to recheck supplements, but you're still doing things to help your
body kill cancer in the better. If it's raising its up the head or it's in remission or
you're still doing everything you're doing. Make sure you continue with the rise.
The only thing would be just tweaking things. So, if we have to tweak,
there isn't anything specific like, oh, you have cancer in these two spots, so we definitely need to
add this. No. So, we need to just tweak through a cheek swab and see if there's any changes that we need to make.
That would be the only thing for the amount of treatment with respect to the amount of income.